[Musique]
à
bienvenue au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines les futures
stars de la discipline se retrouvent ici
mais aussi sur le parcours du golf de
saint-nom-la-bretèche pour les
championnats du monde de golf amateur
par équipe ça a débuté ça y est la
compétition dames se déroule cette
semaine la compétition hommes se
déroulera la semaine prochaine et on
vous emmène à la découverte de cet
événement c'est parti
[Musique]
et je suis avec maïtena alsuguren
la directrice technique nationale
adjointe de la fédération française de
golf déjà cet événement ces championnats
du monde amateurs par équipe ne déroulé
plus dans les yvelines et en france
depuis 1994 ça vous tenait à coeur la
fédération de pouvoir ré accueillir cet
événement oui tout à fait c'est ça fait
partie des plus belles épreuves amateur
au monde
donc ça nous tenait à coeur d'
accueillir à nouveau cette épreuve qui
plus est sûre sur le parcours du golf
national qui accueillit la ryder cup et
qui va accueillir les jo en 2000 24 mai
donc la particularité on est ici à ce
golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines mais la compétition se déroule
aussi à saint nom la bretèche à cause du
nombre de délégations il ya beaucoup
d'allégations accueillir exactement
il ya 56 équipes dames et je crois 62
mémoire 72 équipes messieurs ce qui fait
que pour que tous le monde joue il ya
également le super parcours de
saint-nom-la-bretèche qui accueille
l'épreuve et qui notamment à qu'il
accueillera le final de l'épreuve film
zéro donc cette semaine qui va dérouler
ce samedi ya un nom qui parle au grand
public en pour parle de golf c'est bien
sûr tiger woods il était présent
justement pour cette dernière édition
france en 1994 ça veut dire qu'ici on
retrouve les futurs grands noms du golf
on va retrouver ses futures grandes
exactement vous avez ici
tous les tous les meilleurs joueurs et
les meilleurs joueuses amateurs qu'on va
retrouver qui vont passer pro et tous
pratiquement les plus grands noms ont
disputé cette épreuve des championnats
du monde par équipes il ya quatre jours
de compétition dames quatre jours de
compétition quel est le format de cette
compétition justement alors
effectivement quatre jours de
compétition dans ce qu'on appelle stroke
play donc trois joueurs trois jours
trois joueurs qui jouent tous les jours
on prend les deux meilleures
performances de chaque équipe qu'on
additionne tous les jours et les toutes
les équipes jouent alternativement
à le parcours du golf national et de
saint nom la bretèche donc toutes les
équipes jeu deux fois le golf de
saint-nom-la-bretèche et le gold & golf
national une dernière question les
chances françaises quels sont les
objectifs pour pour ces mondiaux
amateurs alors les pour être très très
pragmatique on va dire que l'équipe
l'équipe qu'on a formé féminine est une
équipe en devenir avec des joueuses
potentiel jeune on est la deuxième
équipe la plus jeune du champ donc c'est
déjà ce sont trois joueuses qui sont
championnes d'europe par équipes moins
de 18 ans en titre donc elles ont déjà
un niveau de jeu certains pour autant
c'est leur premier championnat du monde
et l'idée c'est aussi de les préparer de
les former pour l'avenir sur cette
équipe jeune je pense qu'on sait si tu
as une 12e place si on a environ si on
additionne un petit peu tous les
classements mondiaux et puis sur les
messieurs on a une équipe un petit peu
plus forte sur le papier toujours ça
c'est la théorie la pratique est un
autre sujet donc les skis et sûre sur
les deux équipes c'est qu'elles vont
s'investir s'impliquer et défendre et
jouer crânement comme on dit leur chance
sur les sur les deux épreuves merci
maïté veille justement vous parliez de
cette délégation française on a pu
rencontrer les joueuses de la délégation
française je vous propose d'écouter ses
réactions c'est mon premier engagement
c'est peut-être aussi le dernier je sais
pas et
tapé le premier choc de ce remaniement
c'est un truc de fou j'avais les j'avais
des picotements ventre enfin c'était la
boule au ventre même j'avais il ya mon
club qui est venu qu'il ne me supportait
donc c'est je vais remercier normalement
et c'était génial de leur part puis bien
représenter mon pays c'est c'est quelque
chose que j'adore que j'essaie de faire
au mieux à chaque fois et et je vais
essayer de perfectionner pour le faire
de maison c'est vrai que les premiers
trous c'est tu sens vraiment en coeur
battre à fond et c'est une sensation
incroyable dans ma partie avec la
troisième mondiale donc donc c'est vrai
que quand tu les vois jouer dans les
rangs des poteaux moment elles font
plein de coups vraiment
vraiment au moment où il faut et du coup
c'est ça qui est ça qui fait la
différence c'est qu'en championnat du
monde donc on est assez stressé mais je
pense que le stress il est passé assez
vite et je pense que j'ai réussi assez
assez rapidement à me concentrer sur moi
mais parcours il ya un super bonne et
allegrini sont appelés faire un essai
puis moi je vais vous serez souvent donc
je le connais pas mal
wes est apte à jouer ici
[Musique]
les golfeurs du monde entier sont bien
sûr présents pour cet événement il y
aura la semaine prochaine 72 délégations
pour le tournoi hommes cette semaine
pour le tournoi dames se sont à 56
délégations qui sont présentes nous
avons pu rencontrer quelques golfeuses
qui se sont essayés sur le parcours de
l'albatros on le rappelle c'est le
parcours qui accueillit la ryder cup
2018 elle témoigne notre micro
au niveau des commandes est ok
j à
madina une odeur
voilà rendez vous jusqu'au 27 août pour
le tournoi dames le 3e homme se déroule
la semaine prochaine du 31 août jusqu'au
3 septembre on le rappelle 1-2 site
accueille cet événement des championnats
du monde le golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et aussi le
golf de saint nom la bretèche l'entrée
est gratuite la compétition n'attend
plus que vous